[Music]
Taron I want you to do well I want you
to have a great life
I love you but we cannot see a way that
you can live under this roof if you're
gonna fundamentally go against the grain
of our beliefs Jaron tell me the truth
it's all I think about men I don't know
why I'm so sorry your parents signed you
up for a program to fix you but here you
are a perfectly normal very healthy
teenage boy they're gonna do things for
you you want to say welcome to the
refuge program from you cannot be born a
homosexual this is alive
it's your choice go fake it till you
make it become the man you are not save
yourself Karen God will not love you the
way that you are is this what you want
who's gonna start this demon down
I'm having a tough time I'm gonna give
you some advice tell them whatever they
want to hear
play the part unless you really think
I've been changed or even want to what
you going through right now is just a
moment a moment yes a moment
I love God and I love my son for your
father it's a little more complicated we
are not finished I am because you won't
listen your father is sitting here
telling how you hate him
I'm not gonna pretend I hate my father I
don't hate my father and where is all
this anger come because you're making me
angry
they say sometimes you gotta hurt a
child in order to help them but I'm not
suppose when something is arrived I
don't want to pretend anymore I've had
to ask myself and God if I'm ready to
lose you
[Music]
watch your lover
[Music]
you